Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in
chapter number five, the chapter of
chapter of vigilance of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
the third narration, the 62nd narration
in in order of from the beginning of
the book
authored by
Muhamad
Abu Zakaria.
This narration is on the authority of Ib
Abbass. Iban Abbass. What's his first
name?
Huh? Abdullah and his
Abbi
and his relationship to the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
Iban Am is his paternal cousin his
first paternal cousin correct what's
interesting about Abdullahb Abbas is he
is referred to as
the the scholar of the and what's
interesting about Abdullahb Abbass is
that he was very very young during
During the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam's
time
do we remember which year he was born
Abdullahbn Abbas was born in which what
year?
three years before hijra, right? And but
in in most generous estimates, five
years before hijra either way, because
he was born,
right, during the famine and that lasted
roughly a couple of years. So some
estimates place him at about 13 years
old when he passed away, 14, the most
generous are 15. But we know he was with
the prophet sallall.aii
and that Abdullahb
didn't get to spend that much time with
the prophet because he was so young and
he was with him in his time before
Hijah and then after Hijra he was with
his father until
they were reunited with the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam After the
conquest of Mecca,
Abdullahb Abbass had a very particular
dua made for him.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam made
dua forb. He said
he said said, "Oh Allah,
give
or bless, bestow upon this young boy
understanding of the religion
and teach him the
meaning and the
of the Quran.
And so his specialties became
the
narration of hadith.
His specialty in what he is most most
known for is his taps of the Quran. He
is the companion with the single most
comprehensive
commentary on the book of Allah. And
Abdullahb Abbass was viewed as such
held in such high regard, such high
esteem
that during the battles of the
during the battles of the
in the era of
because when they came back from
huh
[Arabic recitation]
Ali's army came back to Iraq from the
where there were a few skirmishes they
had gone back and
went back to each one took their
respective armies with them and they
had all agreed that each one will choose
a representative from each side and they
will meet and they will try to talk this
out discuss this these
from amongst the they said that and
has judged by other than Allah's book
his place in men taken their words over
the words of Allah over the Quran and
blah blah blah as al fitna usually is it
is wagging tongues.
And so they refused to go back into
Iraq.
They
stopped there at a place on the
outskirts and they mustered together
there a few thousand men. It was said
5,000. Other estimates place them at
about 7,000.
and they said they're not going to come
back until
repents to Allah from his kufur.
And so
what happened is now they started to
present a threat to the Muslim. No one
could pass by without being
ransacked.
Fear of murder and they were killing
people and people were disappearing.
People were were were traveling and and
going missing. Companions were going
missing. Women were found murdered.
Babies were found cut out of their
woman's out of their mother's wombs.
Right?
And so it became a problem. This
had to deal with this. So he decided to
send someone
to go to them
and expel any doubts or shouhat that
they may have.
Now this of course needs to be someone
who is very knowledgeable that's going
to undertake such a thing. Who did he
choose for this?
Abdullahb
and thousands of people repented and
conceded upon
upon Abdullahbn Abbah
upon his arrival to them and
discussion with him.
Abdullahbn Abbas was also
one of the main
in
the Hajj season.
And
said that
he has he gave a he heard him give a
commentary on
that was so compelling that if the
Persians and Romans would have heard his
commentary
they would have accepted Islam. So
Abdullahbn Abbass is a very major
scholar of Islam and his most prominent
his most prominent
legacy is that an entire school of
thought was developed around him with
its own methodologies and its own
scholars and students and shuk known as
Madraset Mecca in the tile of
Abdullahb Abbass
passed away in the year 58 after Hijra.
Now who passed away in the year right
after him that we've discussed here
before
very good passed away in the year 59
after hb
Abbass passed away in the year 58 after
have we ever heard the narration
of Abdullahb Abbass
praying with the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam when he was a child.
The prophet sallallah.aii Wasam was
married to Abdullah and Abbass's
right to Abdullahb Abbass's
maternal aunt right and
Abdullahb Abbz is a very young boy he
was again as we mentioned
at the time of Hij from 3 to 5 years old
so the oldest he was was 5 years
because of his young age, because of his
relationship
with
his aunt Maya.
He
would on occasion sleep over at Mayuna's
house on the night on her night on the
night when you know the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam would stay
there on her night and he would sleep
over there so that he could observe the
prophet sallall.aii
am in.
And so of course he's a child, five
years old, four years old, right? The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam wakes up
and he makes wudoo and then he stands
for salah. Of course, when he came over,
he said to his aunt, "If
he wakes up, wake me up." Right? He's a
child. So, you know, that was taken with
a grain of salt. She didn't do so. He
woke up on his own
and was watching him
while not I wouldn't say pretending to
be asleep but you know as far as he
could see was asleep watched him get up
make woo stand for salah then he got up
made woo in the exact same way stood for
salah with him stood on his left side
right? Stood on his left side
and the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
then took him and moved him to his right
side in one wording.
He took him by the by the braid of his
hair. You know they would have three or
four braids. Took him by the braid and
put him around. He prayed all night with
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. This
is a 5-year-old boy. This man was meant
for greatness.
Abdullahb Abb
has very few narrations that he heard
from the prophet directly.
Again, he was so young and he had spent
so
little time with him directly.
All right.
Some estimates place it at about 40
narrations. Others place it at about 20
or 25.
Really, if we were to look at what he
has directly taken from the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam, it would be about
14 or 15 narrations.
But then when we look at how many
narrations are on the authority of
Abdullahb Abbass, they are in the in the
hundreds.
He's one of the most prolific narrators
of hadith.
And so this is what we refer to as
Morel. Who remembers?
Morosel sahabi morelus sahabi meaning
that he narrates something a companion
narrates something that we know he
wasn't there for or he didn't hear
directly he had to have heard it from
someone else
however because
anyone else he would have heard it from
is a companion for sure we don't have to
know always who that person is most of
the time we do not always and so
Abdullah Iban Abbass spent his time
studying to the discouragement of many
of his peers. Abdullahb Abbass is a
family member of the prophet sallall.ai
In the kingdom of belief, in the kingdom
of Eman, the empire of Eman and the
hierarchy of Eman, he is royalty. He is
as close to royalty as possible.
Yet he demanded no special treatment and
he would spend his days waiting at the
doors of the major companions such as
Abdullahb Masoud and others to accompany
them when they would go for
to the masid, when they would walk to
take that minute to to walk with him to
be able to squeeze in a question or
observe him, right? And he was seen
camped out at the doorways of the elder
companions
during times of rain and dust and cold
waiting for these companions to come out
to accompany them. And when he was asked
about how he
learned so much,
how were you able at such a young age to
learn so much? He said,
he says with a heart that
is expecting and when it receives a
piece of knowledge, it holds on to it
and ties it down and with a tongue that
is constantly asking. But he wouldn't
ask silly questions. He wouldn't ask
questions based on impulse. He was very
very calculated in the things that he
would ask. A lot of times we don't
benefit and we'll end with this
[Arabic recitation]
A lot of times we have we do not benefit
as much as we could from the people of
knowledge because we don't know how to
ask questions properly or because we
don't refine our questions properly.
When you think about asking a question
about a topic,
you want to make sure that you turn this
question around in your mind and refine
it so that you get what you're looking
for and you receive the answer to the
actual question that you have. Not just
let me ask you a question. Yeah, but
what about this? Yeah, but what about
that? What about this? what about that?
It doesn't work that way. That's not how
questions are asked. First, when a
person has a question, they make sure
that they don't have the access to the
answer to that question
in their orbit. Second of all, they
make sure that the question itself
is reflecting what it is they're trying
to understand. Because half of knowledge
is what the question. Half of it half of
knowledge is the question. The other
half is the answer to that question. And
so just as we refine knowledge, we have
to refine our questions to those answers
and that knowledge. And the third thing
is we have to make sure that we choose
the appropriate time, the appropriate
setting, etc. Abdullahb Abbass and this
is a final story about Abbass.
Abdullahb Abbass
had a question about the statement of
Allah.
This is speaking about two
individuals, two women and two of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam's wives.
This verse
he's unsure which of those wives it is
exactly.
Abdullahb Abb spent an entire year
refining his question, waiting for the
most opportune moment to ask
this question. Which two wives were
intended by this verse? An entire year.
When was the moment that he chose he
accompanied
to to Hajj and
on the way there,
you know, when they stopped to to the
caravan stopped to, you know, for him to
relieve himself, people to do what they
have to do, he went to relieve himself
and Iban Abbass accompanied him. Now he
had access to Omar at any time all
through Omar's Abbas had direct access
to him always because he was part he was
a member of Omarab's
even though he was barely 20 years old
he was one of the sh members of Kab he
had access to him daily yet in spite of
that he didn't ask his question until
finally Finally, he found this time
because he wanted to get as much
knowledge from him as possible regarding
this verse. So, if he would have asked
him at a less desirable moment,
he would ask who's intended by this
verse, we'd say
that's it. That's the answer. But that's
not what happened then, is it? When he
asked him, he said,
I have been waiting for a year to ask
you this question. I'm hesitant.
However, who did Allah intend by this
verse? He said,
and then he gave him a long detailed
story of the exact
events that occurred
before the revelation of this verse.
So he didn't just get the answer, he got
the entire context that he was wanting.
And that's why he hesitated to ask him
for so long. Maybe that day Omar was
uncomfortable. Maybe he's in a hurry.
Maybe he's you know busy. His
mind's busy about something. He waited
for the perfect moment to get the
knowledge that he was that he was
intending. And this is why Abdullahbn
Abbath has given us every one of us has
done a service for us that we could
never repay him for. So,
[Arabic recitation]